encore une journée enfin voilà que ça
voilà on a qu'à attendre une nouvelle
date
vous pouvez pas faire les questions les
réponses
c'est vous qui dites ça non non
quand on sait rien on dit pas je dis
qu'il y a une intercer syndicale ce soir
et comme vous y serez vous demanderez
vous verrez ce qui s'y passe alors très
très simple l'objectif de la journée
d'aujourd'hui après discours de Macron
hier l'objectif c'est de montrer que la
détermination et la colère elle est
encore elle est toujours aussi
importante voire plus je pense qu'elle
n'est plus d'ailleurs et donc l'objectif
c'est toujours la même chose retirer
votre projet
[Musique]
ici si il pouvait rien on se prépare
ce que vous considérez qu'on est
défaitiste qu'on avait célébra vu la
mobilisation aujourd'hui bien sûr on est
en pleine forme et pas que la dirigeant
de la terre syndicale
l'ensemble du monde du travail des
retraités les jeunes la détermination
elle est grande oui vous avez entendu le
Président hier dire un peu en cours
simplifier vous avez beau défiler il ira
jusqu'au bout en marche forcée c'est pas
la première fois qui dit ça
alors ils le disent depuis le 10 janvier
en 19
[Musique]
on répond par il faut de la mobilisation
surtout de
proposer lui la question pour une fois
c'est pas moi qui nous avait reçu
premièrement il a il a repris des
arguments que même le gouvernement n'ose
plus avoir il a voulu faire de la
pédagogie comme si on était des
imbéciles et qu'on n'avait pas compris
cette réforme la deuxième chose c'est il
a
il n'a pas répondu à la colère il a il a
pas il a parlé comme mais c'est son
habitude comme un professeur et j'ai
rien contre les profs mais sachant un
expert qui explique à des imbéciles ce
qu'il faut penser ce qu'il faut croire
etc et puis il y a eu aussi un peu de
je vais dire un peu mais
beaucoup de mépris quand il compare les
mobilisations sociales en France avec ce
qui s'est passé aux États-Unis où au
Brésil
c'est une insulte pour ceux qui se
mobilisent ici enfin il n'est pas des
gens d'extrême droite vous le savez très
bien notamment les syndicats ont
toujours dit pas d'extrême droite chez
nous qui les la question est pas la même
ici on a affaire une question sociale on
remet pas en cause d'une élection et
puis je lui ai dit moi ça ça m'a fait
rire parce que j'ai de l'humour quand un
président de la République dit c'est pas
normal que les minimats de branches soit
en dessous du SMIC vraiment il était pas
content ça fait deux ans qu'on a écrit à
Jean castexte c'est un premier ministre
donc en lui disant il faut il y a un
problème il faut que quand le SMIC
augmente automatiquement les minima de
branchement et qui nous a répondu à nous
a répondu
circuler il y a rien à voir enfin vous
voyez c'est c'est
surréaliste le truc mais comment vous
expliquer le fait que pardon il dit
avoir du respect pour les syndicats vos
actions etc et en même temps et en même
temps il ne veut pas vous recevoir
comment vous expliquer cette
j'ai rien
mais probable à l'appui parce qu'on lui
a écrit pour demander
c'est pas président premièrement depuis
10 kg et nous on est dans la rue
déterminé en colère beaucoup de
mobilisation beaucoup de grève beaucoup
de monde dans les manifestations on est
proche des chiffres du 7 mars vous voyez
que on est loin de le mouvement est loin
de s'essouffler des grèves dans beaucoup
d'entreprises évidemment lui il peut
pratiquer la méthode Coué la réalité de
du pays elle est ici ah l'Élysée
qui se passe des choses en marge des
manifestations c'est à dépasser la
dernière fois l'avant dernière fois nous
ce qu'on sait c'est que les la
détermination la colère elle s'exprime
de façon pacifique dans les cortèges
avec des slogans clairs net précis on a
connu le président résumé aussi à votre
place que il y a de l'injustice et qu'il
entend la justice notamment d'aller
chercher les gens qui ne travaillent pas
au RSA est-ce que c'est quelque chose
que qu'il a entendu dans dans vos ou
alors pas du tout il rêve
je sais pas ce qu'il entend l'Élysée moi
mais je trouve qu'il devrait sortir un
peu de l'Elysée pour écouter la vraie
vie
c'est
le dernier
vous me prenez pour un clown c'est ça
ma dernière manif peut-être la dernière
à la place où je suis c'est-à-dire
derrière la banderole de tête et
sûrement pas la dernière maille j'espère
ça sera pas de ma faute hein
c'est bon vous avez posé à cette
question
si j'en ai
[Musique]